joined Now by one of the signatories the
former brexit secretary David hi it's
good to see you thanks for joining us on
the program what do you want to see
happen well the what's happening at the
moment got 12 000 albanians in one year
from a safe country you know it's a
member of the European convention on
human rights as we are and I want two
things to happen we want two things
happen at one uh such people to be told
you can't claim Asylum here immediately
a summary decision on that there's no
argument for Asylum from Albania here
secondly those who use the human
trafficking laws which will save them
look if you have been human trafficked
surely the right answer is to put you
back in your own home in your own
village back in Albania if you want to
process it beyond that then talk to us
after that but you're going home the
point is to turn the turnaround time for
for an Albanian landing on our Shores uh
from years to days or weeks and that's
the aim and we think it's possible if we
don't do it the hummus is never going to
be able to cope with the number of
applications it's gonna it's already 420
days to get a decision it'll get longer
and longer and eventually all those
decisions will allow people to say see
the home office doesn't agree with you
because of the 55 percent of Asylum
applications by adults albanians
um they've been they've been allowed to
stay no what's what's been happening to
it if you if you turn into two two
groups young men which is the vast
majority and uh women and children women
and children beginning about 85 approval
that's because the the home office
itself has not been interpreting the
Asylum laws correctly if so it's the
home office as well not the album It's a
mixture at the end of the day the blame
for this lands of the Albanian gangs who
bring them here not the albanians
themselves because they're all sorts of
failures of people it's the Albanian
gangs that bring them here but the
simple truth is that the home office is
interpreting Asylum laws to say if you
are in our in Albania not if a
government is oppressing you which is
what Asylum laws are like so you've been
talking about China somebody came from
China saying my government's going to
kill me we give them Asylum but if
they're facing gangsters criminal
activities inside their own country
that's a misinterpretation of the Islam
laws it was never designed for that well
interestingly the Albanian prime
minister saying that he's not having
albanians being scapegoated because of
failed policy here in the UK well I mean
I'm not escaping the individual
albanians what I'm saying is at the The
Gangs before you set off across the
channel if you're a migrant the
albanians are gangs brief them on how to
use loopholes in our law what I want to
do is to close those loopholes so if you
like I'm agreeing with the Albanian
prime minister we need to to fix our own
problem he needs to fix some too in
terms of traffic out of his country okay
you talk about um people not being able
to come here if you've come from a safe
country surely that means France Yeah
well yeah well it does I mean there's a
secondary issue here which which we
haven't addressed in this because you've
been going on for years and nobody seems
to be able to resolve it and that is
that any uh Asylum Seekers real primary
right is to be able to stop in the first
con first safe country they arrive in
right so that could be France in this
case if they've crossed Europe it's
about six other countries right but we
we can't enforce that but what we can do
is say you're an Albanian you go back to
Albania isn't that the problem though
that we can't enforce that isn't that
where the problem there are there are
several links in this problem what we're
we're not addressing that one as well
because we're focusing on the one that's
quickest to fix I mean this one if the
if the government puts through emergency
legislation very very unusually I mean I
normally oppose a much solicitation but
very very unusual is a very very strong
argument for doing this be a very short
bill it will go through and basically we
could say to the Albanian population now
anybody else who comes across the
channel will be sent back and when that
starts to happen there's no bigger
deterrent remember the home office's
argument on the Rwanda policy for
example is this is a deterrent think
there's no bigger deterrent than if
somebody in your village pays thousands
of pounds to it to a human trafficker
and then ends up back in the village
three weeks later yeah
um I'm glad you brought up Rwanda
because how's that working out for this
question well I'm not fan of reminders I
mean I've got to be careful because I
don't uh not everybody who signed a
letter agrees with me on that but I'm
not a fan of Rwanda policy because we've
spent 140 million and the indications
are that even if it works at all it
won't take more than 200 people it's
very it's it's a bad idea it won't work
yeah but my point is that it's a piece
of legislation that was put through the
House of Commons by this government and
it has not been successful why do you
think emergency legislation which is
rushed through by you know it's very
description is going to be any more
effective because this addresses the two
main loopholes that are used by people
traffickers to bring people into Britain
illegally that's what it does two main
loopholes one is in our uh in our Asylum
law one is in our trafficking law and
interestingly in November of 2021 I
think it was uh Sweden looked to this
and said
we're going to stop anybody claiming
Asylum from a safe country in this case
Albania and you know what they've
approved zero since a nobody's taken
them to court
um talk to me about
um the Tory Exodus while I've got you um
a lot of youngsters I'll describe them
as that Danny Davidson particularly I
mean she wasn't even born when you
became everybody see youngster
in the same case you're a child what's
going on oh well I think people uh some
people are deciding they don't they
they've they came into politics they
enjoyed it for a while now they don't
you know I mean William Bragg is he said
it's he had a great time he's been
chairman of the committee and so on
while he's still young enough to to have
another career he's going to go and do
that you know that sort of thing that
sort of thing I can't tell you the
answers to all those I mean you know I'm
going to be here till I die in harness I
suspect um although am I right in saying
that your constituency is going to be
affected by boundaries again oh cutter
bits again you know yeah yeah third time
I mean I end up with about half of my
existing constituency
um but what's been the case since well I
mean
since over a decade
um is we've got in the eyes of the
boundary commission at least one too
many MPS for what was the old humbicide
that's East Yorkshire and Lincolnshire
and so they had to shrink them down and
uh so one will go and the boundary
change or the boundary commission
battery change commission
um do you think that they have the best
interests of the your constituents and
others in mind when they come up with
these new boundaries well I'm sure they
intend to
um whether they get it exactly right
well there's a consultation process we
are actually currently engaged in a
consultation process on that and uh
indeed we've I've talked to them I will
be writing them rather about one
component of my current constituency to
try and ensure that it stays together
rather than get broken up Center this
piece in that piece uh can I ask you
about wind farms where are you on that
um I'm not in favor of this so-called
Tory rebellion in favor of uh
liberalizing the law on wind farms
I've got one right next to I mean nearly
as close as the camera to my house
um the uh but but yeah it wasn't there
yes frankly but yeah it ruins the
skyline but so what the more important
Point here is that we've got offshore
wind farms now coming we've got to be
sure that when we go towards heading uh
hitting net zero that we do it in a way
that takes the population with us takes
the takes the the nation with us and
that that me that applies to whether
it's wind farms or massive solar Farms
now that we're covering half the half
the country were great tranches of the
country and uh in solar Farms fine let's
go down let's make it a least responsive
to the ideas of local people
um Before I Let You Go it would appear
that the way for conservative MPS to be
popular is to go on to I'm a celebrity
I think that's what Rishi cynics are
doing no certainly not no no I mean look
I I I've had to spend time in a jungle
eating horrible things but never on
television and and I wouldn't recommend
it it's good to see you thank you so
much for taking the time to join us this
morning I really appreciate it thank you